[Musique]
je mets de l'huile de sésame sur les
dents non c'est un conseil beauté que
celui d'accor en fin de bouche à l'huile
de sésame est magnifique certes il
s'était plaint et merci dit ou tu ferais
pas une aide plus dans ces conditions là
on est frais lens nord fraîcheur de
ginza my weapon comme moi je m'appelle
ouais je t'aime tu appelles comme moi je
m'appelle ouest m tu fais beaucoup de
peine là on est là on est très lentement
fraîcheur demi de la veille
franchement je pas vigilants bref au gas
wave ou là mais moi je m'apprête à la
mairie moi je m'appelle way
[Musique]
elle peut bouger sur place et peut pas
faire
vois tu te places là et là il ya cyril à
côté de toi
et là on va t'envoyer le sont d'accord
c'est qu'enfin quoi je donne prise 2
[Musique]
tu peux cap et se paie 7 membres pour
moi
[Musique]
passé
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
nicolas boutet